y
en una aparente desescalada rusia
aseguró que 10.000 militares se están
retirando de su frontera con ucrania
pero miles de tropas permanecen en el
lugar por lo que los temores continúan
ante una posible invasión a territorio
ucraniano
por primera vez en toda la pandemia
francia superó los 100.000 contagios
diarios de kobe 19 registrando 104 mil
casos en medio de la rápida propagación
de la variante omicron el presidente de
manuel macrón convocó a un consejo de
salud para estudiar la respuesta
en su mensaje de navidad del papá
francisco enfatizó que el diálogo es la
solución para resolver todos los
conflictos desde disputas familiares
hasta la guerra entre los países para
américa pidió que se respeten el derecho
y los valores culturales de todos
[Música]
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy marinera calle y es un placer
estar con ustedes y más de 10.000
soldados rusos se estaría retirando de
las regiones cerca de ucrania para
volver a sus bases así lo informó la
agencia oficial de noticias interfax
citando fuentes del ejército ruso el
retiro se da en medio de las tensiones
entre el kremlin y occidente por los
señalamientos de una posible invasión a
territorio ucraniano por parte de moscú
aunque rusia lo niega xavier colás
nuestro corresponsal en rusia que está
en españa' por las festividades tiene
más información tras un mes de
ejercicios sobre el terreno los
militares rusos parece que están
dirigiéndose a sus guarniciones de
origen o eso es lo que dice moscú el
mando del distrito militar sur del
ministerio de defensa de rusia ha
anunciado que más de 10.000 efectivos
desplegados en las regiones cercanas a
la frontera con ucrania ahora están
emprendiendo el regreso a sus
guarniciones de origen desde el
ministerio de defensa se precisa que los
militares se retiran tras un mes de
ejercicios sobre el terreno esto en
principio es una buena noticia llega
después de semanas de tensiones entre
rusia y la otan y con muchas
especulaciones sobre una posible nueva
agresión de rusia contra ucrania ahora
mismo se sabe que las tropas rusas
estaban muy cerca de la frontera pero
ahora es rusia la que acusa de nuevo a
occidente la portavoz del ministerio de
exteriores de rusia ha dicho en una
rueda de prensa que hay cerca de 10.000
instructores militares procedentes de
países occidentales ahora mismo en
ucrania en teoría ayudando al gobierno
de kiev a perpretar una nueva
provocación
la celebración de la nochebuena y la
navidad se vio marcada por segundo año
consecutivo por la pandemia en francia
por primera vez se registraron más de
100.000 contagios de kobe 19 en un solo
día en gran parte por la variante
omicron por otra parte más de 6000
vuelos han sido cancelados en todo el
mundo desde el jueves mientras que las
tripulaciones de varias aerolíneas
estadounidenses están en cuarentena
asistente no invitado a la navidad
omicron causa el peor récord de nuevos
contagios en francia 104 mil personas
dieron positivo porque hoy 19 en las
últimas 24 horas el lunes el presidente
de manuel macrón convocó una reunión de
emergencia para discutir las medidas a
adoptar
la nueva variante sigue dejando cifras
máximas en europa lo que ha obligado a
los jefes de estado y de gobierno a
reponer restricciones que marcan los
festejos claro en otras ocasiones hemos
ido a celebraciones grandes en sitios
abiertos pero como están las cosas
preferimos estar solos en el mundo ya
son 6.000 vuelos cancelados según el
portal especializado flightaware los
contagios de los empleados de las
aerolíneas son algunos de los motivos
especialmente de vuelos desde y hacia
eeuu en un comunicado la asociación de
aerolíneas estadounidenses pidió a los
centros de control de enfermedades
reducir el aislamiento de 10 días a los
contagiados por kobe 19 proponemos un
periodo de aislamiento de no más de 5
días desde el inicio de los síntomas
para aquellos que experimentan la
infección
los tradicionales festejos de fin de año
en lugares emblemáticos como el times
square de nueva york y la puerta del sol
de madrid ya fueron modificados para
hacerle frente al cobro y 19 se redujo
el aforo y se exigirán mascarillas y
pruebas de vacunación
desde la basílica de san pedro el papá
francisco dio su mensaje urbi et orbi
que en latín significa a la ciudad y al
mundo allí afirmó que la humanidad
necesita más diálogos para superar toda
clase de conflictos y mencionó algunas
guerras como las de siria yemen y
afganistán
frente a una plaza que estaría
completamente llena de feligreses de no
ser por el cob y diecinueve por segundo
año consecutivo el papá francisco
entregó su tradicional mensaje de
navidad bajo la sombra de la pandemia y
pidió por el fin de la crisis lío con
los
con ch de salud que hay mal dios con
nosotros concede salud a los enfermos e
inspira a todas las personas de buena
voluntad para que encuentren las
soluciones más adecuadas que ayuden a
superar la crisis sanitaria y sus
consecuencias para que los corazones
sean generosos para hacer llegar la
asistencia necesaria
especialmente las vacunas a las
poblaciones más pausini a la populación
y provisorios
como es habitual la misa urbi et orbi
que traduce a la ciudad y al mundo se
convirtió en una dura descripción de la
actualidad el pontífice aprovechó para
enumerar los conflictos que se viven
alrededor del planeta por ejemplo en
afganistán mianmar ucrania y etiopía y
especialmente en medio oriente
pensamos pensemos en el pueblo de siria
que durante más de una década ha vivido
una guerra que ha provocado muchísimas
víctimas y un número incalculable de
desplazadas oremos a irak que todavía
lucha por recuperarse de un prolongado
conflicto escuchemos el llanto de los
niños que surge en yemen
gateway bambini que si le va a dar o
yemen el papá francisco criticó que se
estén pasando por alto este tipo de
tragedias condenó la creciente
polarización en las relaciones
personales e instó al diálogo con el que
dijo se pueden resolver conflictos que
van desde disputas familiares hasta
amenazas de guerra en cuanto a américa
pidió que en el continente se reconozcan
los derechos de todos
y la reina isabel segundo también envió
su mensaje de navidad la monarca de 95
años recordó a su fallecido esposo y
destacó que aunque la navidad es una
época de felicidad para muchos puede ser
difícil para quienes han perdido a sus
seres queridos también habló de su
jubileo de platino que se conmemora el
próximo año y marca sus 70 años en el
trono siendo la monarca que más tiempo
ha reinado en la historia británica
aunque el coit significa que nuevamente
no podemos celebrar tal y como
hubiésemos querido o podemos disfrutar
de las múltiples tradiciones alegres ya
sea en el canto de villancicos siempre y
cuando sea uno bien conocido decorando
el árbol dando y recibiendo regalos o
viendo nuestra película favorita aunque
ya conozcamos el final nos sorprende que
las familias atesora en sus rutinas
navideñas
al menos 38 personas habrían sido
asesinadas a manos de militares birmanos
en una aldea en el sur de mianmar una
ong local y save the children han
denunciado esta matanza de civiles en
una zona atravesada el conflicto entre
las grillas étnicas del país y el
ejército este último está en el poder
desde el golpe de estado del pasado
primero de febrero
una nube de humo negro marca el lugar de
una masacre la cometida por el ejército
de mi amar en el estado de caya
fronterizo con tailandia según ha
denunciado la ong local karen y human
rights group que cita como fuentes a un
ciudadano local ya la guerrilla knf la
fuerza nacional para la defensa de caya
la ong save the children también informó
del suceso y de la desaparición de dos
de sus miembros dos miembros de nuestro
personal que viajaban a casa durante las
vacaciones después de realizar un
trabajo de respuesta humanitaria en una
comunidad cercana quedaron atrapados en
el incidente y siguen desaparecidos
tenemos confirmación que su vehículo fue
atacado y quemado los militares forzaron
a las personas fuera de sus vehículos
arrestaron a unos mataron a otros y
quemaron los cuerpos entre los muertos y
desaparecidos habría hombres mujeres y
niños todos ellos civiles el ejército no
ha negado el suceso si bien afirma que
se trataba de terroristas armados
a parar en un retén la región se ha
convertido en una zona caliente del
conflicto entre las guerrillas étnicas y
civiles del país y el ejército en el
poder desde el golpe de estado del
pasado 1 de febrero al sur del lugar de
la matanza enfrentamientos entre
guerrillas y militares han llevado
también este sábado al desplazamiento de
numerosos aldeanos en dirección a la
vecina tailandia según activistas
birmanos desde el golpe de estado se han
producido al menos 1300 65 muertes de
disidentes en bangladesh 25 de las 38
víctimas mortales del incendio en un
ferry el pasado viernes fueron
sepultadas la cifra de decesos puede
aumentar pues más de 50 personas están
hospitalizadas y varios pasajeros
continúan desaparecidos luego de la
tragedia ocurrida en el río su banda en
el sur del país
y el 25 de diciembre se cumplen 500 años
de la primera rebelión de esclavos
africanos en américa que sentó bases
para los movimientos de independencia
esto ocurrió en un ingenio azucarero que
pertenecía al virrey diego colom hijo de
cristóbal colón el levantamiento en la
actual república dominicana fue en
contra de los castigos físicos y la
falta de alimentación luego de esto se
promulgó una ley de esclavos para evitar
futuras rebeliones y los capturados
fueron castigados cortándoles los pies o
las manos
y hasta aquí nuestras noticias ustedes
sigan conectados con nosotros
[Música]